bonjour à tous ça fait des mois qu'on en
parle et le grand jour est arrivé apple
annonce et non pas la sortie d'un iphone
2 iphone mais bien de trois iphone pour
marquer le coup à l'occasion des 10 ans
de l'iphone du tout premier iphone qui
avait été présenté en 2007 par steve
jobs
la présentation a eu lieu dans le
nouveau steve jobs créateur directement
aux états unis et là franchement je dois
vous avouer qu'on n'est pas resté sur
notre faim alors deux premiers iphone
qui sont en réalité la suite logique de
ce qu'est l'iphone 7 et l'iphone cette
plus à savoir l'iphone 8 et l'iphone 8
plus est un nouveau venu dont on
attendait effectivement l'arrivée depuis
quelques temps c'est l'iphone dit ce qui
s'écrit avec une grande croix on ne
prononce pas l'iphone os x mais bien
l'iphone 10 l'iphone dès 10 ans l'iphone
anniversaire alors autant les deux
premiers modèles iphone 8 iphone mise
plus sur la réelle évolution de l'iphone
cet iphone os est plus au temps l'iphone
10 est vraiment selon apple ce que doit
être le téléphone du futur une vraie
avancée avec toutes les meilleures
technologies que vont avoir les
smartphones dans les années à venir
alors ce qu'on va faire dans cette vidéo
c'est qu'on va présenter ses trois
téléphones on à les comparer regardez un
peu la différence entre ces trois
modèles et à la fin voir lequel est
intéressant s'il y en a un qui les oui
non pas comment il va en appel de balle
gamme de prix pour les iphone alors déjà
que ce soit l'iphone 8,8 plus ou
l'iphone disent ils font tous les trois
soit 64 giga soit 256 giga les rumeurs
faisaient état d'un potentiel 512 gigard
ce n'est pas le cas en réalité en terme
de dimensions l'iphone 10 se positionne
exactement entre l'iphone 8 et la chaîne
dix de plus par contre en termes
d'écrans l'iphone 8 un écran de 4,7
pouces l'iphone 8 plus 5,5 pouces et
l'iphone 10 5,8 pouces il est plus petit
en dimensions que la conduite plus il ya
un plus grand écran parce que forcément
inoccupés la quasi totalité
smartphone est justement parlons des
écrans que ce soit l'iphone 8 soit une
huile plus ils ont tous les deux un
écran retina hd display l'iphone 8 10
par contre c'est tout autre chose
autant les deux premiers sont des écrans
lcd les écrans lcd qui équipé depuis
longtemps la gamme des iphone l'iphone
dispose vraiment tout autre chose c'est
un écran oled un écran super retina hd
display port à bord en 2004 136 par 1125
évident résolution de 4 158 p pays alors
quand on connaît la qualité des écrans
oled effectivement ils ont des contrats
ce qui sont plus saisissant des couleurs
plus belle et a priori ce nouvel écran
de l'iphone d'ici rit encore plus loin
avec des couleurs beaucoup plus clair
beaucoup plus de brillance vraiment
quelque chose d'extrêmement surprenant
qui serait a priori au dessus de ce
qu'on peut retrouver sur le marché
je pense notamment où lg des 30 que
j'essayais pas longtemps ainsi que le
galaxy note 8 qui ont tous des écrans
oled sont d'une excellente qualité mais
a priori selon les dires d'apple
l'iphone dit ce serait encore au dessus
ils sont tous les trois équipés de la
puce à 11 bionique à six coeurs côté
appareil photo on retrouve sur l'iphone
8 un capteur de 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture en 1.8 l'iphone 8 + a par
contre deux capteurs en 12 mégapixels
chacun un grand angle et un téléobjectif
le grand-angle à l'ouverture en 1.8
était l'objectif en 2.8 l'iphone 10 a
lui aussi un double capteur 12
mégapixels qui par contre sont à la
verticale une ouverture pour le rotengle
de 1.8 et le thé l'objectif est une
ouverture en 2.4 ce qui permettra
d'avoir plus de lumière par rapport aux
deux autres modèles l'iphone 8 un zoom
digital x 5 l'iphone 8 plus un zoom
digital et un zoom optique x lice et
c'est la même chose pour l'iphone 10 ce
soit l'iphone 8 + ou l'iphone disent ils
ont tous les deux le portrait mode qu'on
connaissait déjà sur l'iphone cette plus
mais il y a un tout nouveau mode qui
vient d'apparaître c'est le mode éthique
pour l'instant en version bêta il vous
permettra de pouvoir modifier la lumière
de prise de vue
comme si vous étiez dans un studio
professionnel de pouvoir carrément
détour et où le personnage d'avoir un
fond noir et de le ressortir à mettray
la marque chose de très intéressant à
noter que ces deux modes là on les
retrouve sur la caméra bhl de celle
fille de l'iphone 10 une caméra de sel
fille en cette méga pixels alors
puisqu'on parle des caméras de celle
fillon va y rester
puisque la caméra wifi de l'iphone 8 et
de la folie 8 plus ont tous les deux une
caméra de cette fille en cette méga
pixels full hd avec une ouverture en 2.2
c'est exactement la même chose pour
l'école d'ouverture et en 2.2 pour la
caméra telle fille tous ses smartphones
se recharge par induction
à noter que le système de déverrouillage
change entre les iphone 8 et l'iphone 10
l'iphone 8 et l'iphone 8 plus vous avez
comme on le connaissait déjà la fameuse
tête chaibi avec l'iphone 10
on passe à tout autre chose on passe au
faith heidi alors le faith heidi c'est
quoi c'est tout simplement votre caméra
de celle fille qui va reconnaître votre
visage qu'il aura au préalable scanner
qui connaîtra les moindres détails de
votre de votre de votre anatomie de
votre visage et ça vous permettra
effectivement de le déverrouiller juste
en posant son regard sur son iphone
alors comment ça marche vous avez un
capteur infrarouge à l'intérieur
effectivement une caméra il ya plein de
capteurs différents
il ya aussi un capteur de proximité le
tout extrêmement précis il a une chance
sur un million de se tromper contre une
chance sur cinquante mille avec le touch
il dit autant dire que c'est vraiment
sécurisé et ça fonctionne même dans le
noir ça c'est que la caméra infrarouge
que vous portez des lunettes que vous
ayez un chapeau nouvelle coupe
tout ce que vous voulez votre téléphone
sera en mesure de vous reconnaître et le
déverrouiller alors pour les verrouiller
ses hyper simple il suffira de le
regarder il s'activera et ensuite avec
votre doigt vous glisserez vers le haut
qui vous serez sans vos applications
à noter qu'à une vraie sécurisation
niveau du fei si quelqu'un pointe une
photo de vous ça ne marchera pas
d'ailleurs on note que apple utilise
cette caméra de cette méga pixels sur
l'iphone 10 pour pouvoir
animer ce qu'ils appellent les animaux
ji sont des petits angie que vous pouvez
utiliser dans vos messages comme la
caméra reconnaît exactement la forme de
votre visage et l'as cannes et la
numériser en quelque sorte elle est
capable de reconnaître les différents
mouvements et de les appliquer à ces
petits animaux j ce qui permet d'avoir
des choses un petit peu rigolo d'avoir
des messages personnalisés pour faire
parler un cochon un coq une poule tout
ce que vous voulez c'est vraiment très
très marrant alors tous ces smartphones
sont livrés bien évidemment avec le
fameux smartphone en adaptateurs à
lightning usb lightning corps jack vous
avez aussi votre petite prise pour
brancher pour usb et le recharger plus
une documentation
ces trois modèles sont faits en verre
que ce soit sur la face avant ou sur la
face arrière apple a d'ailleurs annoncé
que le ver serait le plus résistant
jamais utilisé sur les iphone donc a
priori pas de risque de casse on a mis
ça vaut quand même le coup d'acheter
petite protection sait-on jamais pour
l'iphone 8 et l'iphone 8 plus on les
trouve en or en argent et en gris quant
à l'iphone 10 on le retrouve en argent
et en gris les trois modèles ont de
nouveau parleurs stéréo 25% plus
puissants que ceux du modèle précédent
et grâce à nouvelle puce à onze on peut
exploiter à fond la réalité augmentée
alors ça vous permettra bien évidemment
de faire des jeux vidéo dans votre pièce
comme si vous y étiez au travers de
votre écran ça permettra d'aborder des
situations super eagles avec différents
jeux ça vous permettra également lorsque
vous serez par exemple à un match de
foot de rugby ou peu importe d'avoir des
informations précises sur les joueurs
pour aller reconnaître c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très sympa et nous
devons s'est présenté une troisième
démonstration vous aurez la carte du
ciel ça permettra effectivement de
savoir quel constellation et là quelques
constellations ça peut être vraiment
vraiment sympa à faire notamment les
belles nuits d'été nous éclaire été
augmenté quelque chose qui va développer
énormément vous allez avoir plein de
nouvelles applications
donc là aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
du gadget et dans les années à venir ça
va devenir vraiment quelque chose de pas
indispensable en tout cas d'
incontournable
les trois smartphones sont équipés d'un
bluetooth 5.0 vous pourrez précommander
l'iphone italie fogny plus à partir du
15 septembre et ils seront disponibles à
partir du 22 septembre au tarif de 699
dollars pour l'iphone 8 et 2 799 dollars
pour l'iphone 8 plus pour l'instant on
n'a pas les tarifs en français mais on
imagine qu'ils seront un petit peu plus
cher on peut imaginer des prix à 750 800
euros pour l'iphone 8 et probablement
850 900 euros pour l'iphone 8 plus c'est
encore bien hypothétique
en règle générale les prix en euros sont
plus élevés que les prix en dollars
annoncés par apple
notez l'iphone 10 sera disponible en
précommande le 27 octobre est disponible
à partir du 3 novembre au tarif de 999
dollars
on imagine bien évidemment que en euro
on dépassera largement les 1000 euros
probablement 1100 euros voire 1200 euros
alors l'arrivée de ces 30 nouveaux
smartphones vont forcément avoir une
répercussion sur les prix au niveau de
la gamme des iphone l'iphone et se passe
à 349 dollars l'iphone 6 aces à 449
dollars l'iphone 7 à 549 dollars
êtes-vous déjà donné tous les autres
détails pour l'iphone 8,8 plus et
l'iphone 10 alors maintenant la question
à se poser c'est quel iphone choisir
vous avez le choix entre effectivement
tout une large gamme d'iphone alors je
dirais que si vous voulez commencer à
rentrer dans la gamme des iphone
l'iphone est ce est très bien mais si
vous voulez tout de suite montrent un
peu plus avec des nouvelles
fonctionnalités et vous amuser passer
directement sur l'iphone 8 voir l'iphone
8 + moi je ne saurais que vous
recommander l'iphone 8 plus pour les
nouveaux modes de prise de photo parce
que c'est des choses qui vont devenir de
plus en plus sympa il prend vraiment
faire des photos de meilleure qualité
donc tout quand on sait qu'on fait
beaucoup de fautes aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est indispensable d'avoir le
meilleur appareil photo
ce que je regrette par contre sur
l'iphone 8 à l'iphone 8 plus c'est la
caméra de cette fille qui n'est à mon
sens toujours pas la hauteur cette méga
pixels
on va pas aller bien loin surtout si
vous êtes youtuber si vous êtes créateur
de contenu vous avez besoin de vous
filmer de pouvoir vous regardez et vous
film en même temps avec cet appareil là
la qualité va pas être extraordinaire
alors bien évidemment vous pourrez
filmer en full hd
pas de quatre cas mais comme le capteur
n'est pas génial vous risquerez d'avoir
un contenu de qualité assez moyenne à
voir que ça donnera par contre sur le
capteur de celles fidèles
10 même s'il est sur un capteur 5
mégapixels on va avoir de nouvelles
performances le capteur quant à lui en
cette méga pixels de l'iphone 10
l'espère un petit peu mieux pour pouvoir
faire des selphy vous peut notamment
utiliser le mode portrait et le mode
lighting directement sur votre caméra
ses deux filles donc il se peut que
cette caméra soit mieux pourquoi pas
pour faire des vidéos sur youtube enfin
ça reste quand même à voir et à tester
en vrai si vous deviez faire un choix
entre l'iphone 8 l'iphone 8 + ou
l'iphone disent mieux qu'elle choisit
alors le premier paramètre c'est
forcément je pars à mettre de l'argent
si je devais en choisir qu'un seul je
prendrais bien évidemment l'iphone
disent pourquoi pour l'écran déjà un
écran oled ont super retina hd forcément
c'est un écran plat d'une extrême grande
qualité un grand écran borderless c'est
la tendance c'est super c'est magnifique
pour avoir vu tourner les écrans elle ce
que vous assurer que vous ne serez pas
déçu par rapport à un écran lcd c'est
vraiment autre chose pour moi le fait sa
vie aujourd'hui c'est vraiment du gadget
pas nécessairement très très intéressant
par rapport au t2 id la vraie différence
le vrai choix doit se faire à mon avis
entre l'iphone 8 plus à l'iphone 10 et
se fera uniquement sur la qualité de
l'écran reste à savoir ce que vous en
pensez vous est-ce que vous avez été
convaincus par ces différents
smartphones qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'iphone windows phone 8 plus de
l'iphone 10
est ce que vous envisagez d'en acheter
un si oui lequel
qu'est ce que vous pensez du prix est ce
que vous êtes surpris par le prix est ce
que vous trouvez ça bien ce que vous
trouvez que le prix de l'iphone 8 est
abordable
on peut s'attendre à plus cher ça peut
rester cohérent dites moi tout ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire était
génial de pouvoir en discuter avec vous
invite à vous abonner marché parce qu'en
toujours plus de contenu pour vous aider
à réussir sur youtube et également à
connaître tous les produits influencer
les produits intéressants pour votre
site sur youtube et aussi dans votre vie
digitale
quant à moi je remercie beaucoup d'avoir
gagné cette vidéo et je vous dis à très
bientôt et d'ici là portez vous bien ça
lui
[Musique]